to use secret tax havens to avoid paying
their legally responsible taxes is in my
mind unconscionable these secrecy havens
are not just offshore we we sometimes
talk about the Panama papers in Panama
but they're also lying through our
theory and Europe they're in the United
States the secret havens are the darker
side of globalization and they are one
of the reasons that globalization only
one of the reasons but one of the
reasons that globalization has not
worked when people see the this darker
side of globalization they got even more
upset with it one of the things reasons
that the Panama papers got such
attention is that they documented in
such a comprehensive way the breadth and
depth of the kinds of illicit activities
that were supported by these secrecy
havens and so it is not just a matter of
depriving governments of revenues
necessary to address poverty growth but
it's because they undermine the
functioning of a normal society
I hope that there will be a greater
resolve particularly in Europe for
dealing with that